[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans sa roue
regarde ravi de vous retrouver vous
l'avez vu l'assemblée nationale sera
présidée par une femme et c'est une
première dans l'histoire elle s'appelle
yaël boon pivert personne ne la
connaissait il ya encore cinq ans
avocate pénaliste à la fibre sociale on
va évidemment revenir sur son parcours
fulgurant c'est une figure emblématique
de la promesse macro nien le dépassement
des clivages le renouvellement de la
classe politique une femme au perchoir
dans un hémicycle sans majorité absolue
qui promet d'être électrique grande
équipe talent dans un instant avec nos
invités une autre femme de pouvoir dans
le fauteuil du grand témoin ce soir est
le pilote le groupe des 72 1 soumis à
l'assemblée elle veut graver dans le
marbre de la constitution le droit à
l'avortement après la décision choc de
la cour suprême américaine de laure
évoqué aux états unis matt hill de
panneaux sera également avec nous ce
soir enfin 2 a franchi céline bracq pour
nous révéler la dernière vague de notre
baromètre au doxa elle n'est pas bonne
pour le couple exécutif vous le verrez
et puis fanny guinochet pour l'économie
alerte rouge sur les comptes publics
alors que les mesures pouvoir d'achat
vont encore alourdir la facture voilà
pour le menu de ces verts ce soir c'est
parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs c'est donc une femme qui
prend pour la première fois les rênes de
la présidence de l'assemblée nationale
permettez moi à ce moment deux mots
promo de mon propos de remercier saluer
mon mari mes cinq enfants qui sont là et
zoua ma fille qui pleure
[Applaudissements]
il me portent leur soutien et leur joie
de vivre sans ma force sans eau sans
chacun de mes proches je ne serai pas
moi je ne serais pas là
ouais donc le large sourire et les
premiers mots de yaël brawn peavey qu'
il y a encore cinq ans ne s'imaginait
pas un jour au perchoir quatrième
personnage de l'état pour celle qui
n'est pas du sérail politique est élu
pour la première fois en 2017 on va
revenir en longueur sur cette élection
historique 14 au perchoir c'est la
première femme depuis 1958 dominique
rousseau bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes constitutionnaliste
professeur des universités membre de
l'institut universitaire de france
bonsoir violette spillebout bonsoir
bienvenue dans ça vous regarde vous êtes
l'un des nouveaux visages de l'hémicycle
le député renaissance du nord le nouveau
no pour la république en marche pour
soir philippe gosselin bons joueurs
ravis de vous retrouver ici je voulais
pas aussi un très grand habitué des
bancs de l'assemblée nationale puisque
c'est votre quatrième mandat députés les
républicains de la manche enfin jean
rémi baudot journaliste politique à
france info et chroniqueur dans cette
émission va nous rejoindre dans un tout
petit instant mais d'abord on rembobine
on va revenir en images sur cette
journée particulière historique l
assemblée si j'ai bien compris la mi
blakowski sa chronique tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bon sens myriam bonsoir
à toutes et à tous si j'ai bien compris
ce soir si j'ai bien compris myriam je
ne vous spoile pas le résultat du vote
si je vous dis que c'est yael brawn
peavey du groupe ensemble qu'est devenue
présidente de l'assemblée nationale non
tout le monde est au courant c'est bon
on vient de le vivre en direct
une surprise que ceux qui n'ont pas
suivi le scrutin vont peut-être
découvrir c'est que ya le besoin de pub
aient été élus dès le deuxième tour de
ce scrutin ce que ça a été une surprise
grâce aux retraites de sébastien chenu
qui lui était le candidat du
rassemblement national à la x tekken
hossa alors j'essaie de vous expliquer
tout ça à l'assemblée parfois compliqué
mais en fait assez simple chenu était le
candidat du fn il obtenu 90 voix c'est à
dire l'ensemble des voix de son groupe
plus une certainement robert ménard mais
comme au premier tour aucun candidat
n'avait obtenu la majorité absolue il
fallait organiser un second tour un
deuxième ou un second tour donc en
retirant sa candidature est donc en nous
demandant à s'abstenir à ses 90 voix
qu'ils l'avaient soutenu bah forcément
ils changent le seuil la majorité
absolue il abaisse considérablement et
sont juste un petit coup de pouce ryan
braun québec qui donc a besoin d'un
seuil moins élevé et peut se faire élire
dès le second tour puisque même plus
d'alluré que devoir aller au troisième
tour ce qui ne s'était jamais fait je
crois dans l'élection d'un président
alors est ce que c'est une manoeuvre
c'est ça la question qu'on se pose c'est
à dire pourquoi ce geste favorable
ailleurs une privée ce qui a eu un
accord entre eux est ce que parce que
c'est des magouilles politiques quelque
chose comme ça on écoute la réponse de
sebastian qui va vous étonner car dit
qu'il n'y a pas de magouilles
non c'est pas un message un message pour
l'institution nous on souhaite que
l'institution elle fonctionne on
souhaite ne pas bloquer l'institution
par des manoeuvres donc par conséquent
partir du moment où ne pousse ne pouvons
pas accéder à la présidence de cette
institution nous sommes satisfaits de
notre score une fois de plus eh bien
nous ne percevront pas pour qu'ils ont
quand même pour eux les gens du
rassemblement national d'avoir dit
depuis le début on ne veut pas de
blocage on veut montrer qu'on est
capable d'être un parti raisonnable et
de gouvernement donc après tout son
argumentation se tient mais évidemment
du côté de l efi on n'en croit pas un
mot on écoute paul vannier
des combines manifestement et peut-être
qu'il ya un message que l'extrême droite
veut adresser à la république en marche
après que la majorité relative le
soutien du trident de la ville donnant
plusieurs semaines pour un jour est
tendu la main à
rassemblement national il ya peut-être
en train de se jouer devant nous un jeu
donnant donnant on sait demain qui a des
important la présidence de la commission
des finances donc s'il doit vraiment
crier au scandale ça sera plutôt demain
s'ils n'ont pas un prix d'émission des
finances c'est là qu'ils vont dire mon
dieu après demain c'est jeudi l'élection
à la présidence de la commission des
finances alors autre source de tension
aujourd'hui le discours du doyen d'âge
le député rassemblement national josé
gonzalez a choqué une partie des députés
alors oui je vous raconte des trucs que
le doyen d'âge donc et membre du
rassemblement national qu'il a 79 ans
qu'il est né je crois à oran ou dans la
région d'oran donc ils étaient rapatriés
en france en 1962 comme pas mal de
français et donc lors de son histoire et
les discours il a évoqué son histoire
personnelle on écoute ce symbole l'unité
touche l'enfant d'une france d'ailleurs
que je suis arraché à sa terre natale et
drossé sur les côtes de provence alpes
par le vent de l'histoire en 1962
j'ai laissé là bas une partie de ma
france et beaucoup d'amis je suis un
homme qui a vu son âme à jamais
meurtries
excusez moi je pense à mes amis que j'ai
laissé la balle
je suis pas omis ou à la polémique
puisque tous les députés ont enfin en
tout cas une bonne partie sont applaudis
et que personne comme parfois ça arrive
ne s'est manifesté pour dire qu'ils
avaient scandale mais effectivement il
ya des gens qui ont été choqués c'est la
gauche
on peut rajouter que pendant la salle
des quatre colonnes se dit en répondant
au journaliste josé gonzalez en a
rajouté un petit peu en disant qu'il
n'était pas là pour décider si l' os
avaient commis des crimes ou pas donc
c'est vrai que c'est parce qu'il a dit à
l'hémicycle donc je vous laisse regarder
le petit tweet voyez comme ça que vous
jugez vous même si vous avez le temps de
lire ses propos donc forcément du côté
de la nuque est ce bien vous vous doutez
bien que on a réagi très vivement
regardez cette fois ci le tweet de
mathilde de panneaux qui elle parle donc
de révisionnisme non ça c'est pas son
tweet mais je vous le dis elle parle de
logis des crimes de la colonisation
donc voilà plutôt que deux
c'est un peu la polémique du jour comme
ça vous vous êtes au courant m'enfin
si on doit retenir quelque chose cette
journée je pense que c'est pas
spécialement cette polémique mais plutôt
le fait que le moment historique c'est
qu'une femme a été élue à la tête de
l'assemblée et donc les polémiques des
défis ben karl olive franchement je
crois pas dit ça l'intéresse tellement
on écoute
d'abord je pense que le doyen était
aussi émus de prendre la parole après je
vais pas commencer à aller chercher
encore une fois de chicaneries là où il
n'ya pas à chercher lâché crime
la gauche fait ce qu'elle a envie de
dire et de partager moi ce que je
constate aujourd'hui c'est que c'est un
moment qui est un moment très important
avec cette ouverture de la 16e
législature et on retiendra que notre
président est une présidente l est pas
elle n'est pas élue parce que les femmes
et les lui parce que c'est la meilleure
donc on résume cet historique une femme
a été élue présidente
on se demande qu'elle joue je le hais
rennes est ensemble et puis si vous avez
le temps il ya nous insoumis de services
qui ont leur petite polémique du jour
donc là vous avez de quoi ça tombe bien
puisque même si le panneau sera avec
nous dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission merci beaucoup stéphane
je vais commencer avec vous est-ce qu
est-ce qu il était temps il a fallu sion
on compte simplement à partir de la 5ème
république 1958 64 ans pour voir une
femme accéder au perchoir bien forcément
aujourd'hui c'était beaucoup d'émotion
pour les femmes et les hommes de voir
l'égalité homme-femme progresser et se
voir aujourd'hui finalement célébrer
avec pour la première fois dans
l'histoire une femme présidente de
l'assemblée nationale ça allait autant
de temps votre avis parce que c'est un
combat que nous avons mené que nos
ancêtres ont mené parce que la culture
de notre société n'était pas fait un si
elle a rappelé d'ailleurs avec beaucoup
d'émotion catherine tasca qui a été la
première présidente de la commission des
lois qui a fait voter sous son mandat la
loi constitutionnel d'égalité femmes
hommes et puis ensuite ça a été des
progrès et des progrès d'année en année
on est aujourd'hui au sein de notre
groupe renaissance environ 40% de femmes
même si une baisse du nombre de femmes
au sein de l'ensemble de l'assemblée
nationale et on va continuer avec aurore
bergé qui est aussi une femme présidente
de notre groupe à promouvoir l'égalité
femmes-hommes après c'est un des sujets
importants mais nous avons aussi les
autres sujets d'action est d'ailleurs en
rappelant toutes les valeurs de la
république et puis aussi son histoire
familiale ce qui était très émouvant
avec les ondes à la règle enfin enfants
qui étaient présents on a aussi vu ce
discours qui terminait par un discours
d'actions et d'actions concrètes pour
toutes les françaises et les français je
crois que c'est là aussi qu'on doit
retenir on est là pour débattre et pas
pour se battre philippe gosselin vous
vous la connaissez très bien on va
regarder un portrait dans un instant
mais déjà ce symbole parce que c'est
important quand même de s'arrêter là
dessus un temps
pourquoi pourquoi il a fallu attendre si
longtemps et est ce que vous voilà vous
féliciter ça veut dire voilà allait elle
est là parce qu'elle est compétente mais
quand même 64 ans c'est long moi je
salue évidemment les compétences et je
le fais sans aucune difficulté vous
noterez d'ailleurs que le groupe ait
l'air avait aussi une candidate annie
jeune frère donc voilà
de l'assemblée il ya le monde privé a
effectivement renvoyer un salut amical -
vous savez ce qui ce qui m'intéresse
c'est qu'on puisse travailler en bonne
intelligence et je constate et je le dis
sans me pincer le nez que nous avons
parfois eu des conflits parfois eu des
rapports un peu punchy avec liane brune
privé à la présidence de la commission
des lois mais que nous avons aussi
réussi à travailler en bonne
intelligence et moi je la salue très
républicaine mans je je je pense et
j'espère qu'elle saura être une femme
d'ouverture comme elle a su le faire
parfois avec un peu de restrictions mais
comme elle a su le faire assez largement
à la commission des lois c'est pas une
compromission que de le dire c'est pas
une magouille que de le dire parce qu'en
ce moment dès qu'on lance un petit
compliment est con qu'on est à peu près
honnête tout de suite on est
non pas du tout je suis ni bikini pour
le chaos donc ça me va très bien mais
mais en tout cas j'espère réellement
qu'elle saura être apaisante dans une
configuration politique n'avait pas
nourrir votre 22 2e tour
écoutez nous on avait encore une
conduite je reste fidèle à la candidate
quelques-uns de vos collègues raphalen
scheelen berger par exemple très
clairement c'est la meilleure candidate
il faut le dire les mêmes mais je pense
je pense que c'est une bonne candidate
effectivement elle sera je l'espère une
bonne présidente n'ya pas polémique à
rémy doisneau cela bien élu finalement
mieux élu qu'on aurait pu l'imaginer
parce que il y a eu ce désistement en
tout cas inattendu d de sébastien chenu
du rassemblement national inattendus ou
stratégiques c'est évidemment la
question qui se pose et qui s'est posé
tout l'après-midi notamment la nuque
accusant donc sébastien chenu de s'être
retiré pour s'attirer les faveurs par la
suite de la majorité présidentielle en
vue et et bien envoyé un message en tout
cas la majorité en vue de de la
commission des finances pour que tanguy
puisse à obtenir le poste bon là on est
dans de la spéculation des dents du
petit jeu partisan la réalité concrète
c'est qu'effectivement en se retirant le
rn a permis de faire baisser la majorité
nécessaire et que donc elle est passé
dès le deuxième tour alors que rappelons
qu'au début de l'après midi on se disait
qu'il est qu'il y en avoir trois
dominique rousseau quel regard que vous
portez comme constitué sur cette séance
un peu un peu différente des autres un
peu différente des autres puisque avant
effectivement il y avait la majorité
absolue pour pour un groupe et par
conséquent le président de l'assemblée
nationale était évidemment élus
immédiatement par par la majorité là il
n'y a pas de majorité absolue il ya une
majorité relative la présidente aurait
de toute façon été élu au troisième tour
donc je vois pas le jeu va pas le
problème de de l'extérieur alors qu'ils
aient eu des compromis des magouilles
mais ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance
elle aurait de toute façon été élu au
troisième tour avec les 340 et une loi
de la majorité la majorité relative ce
qui démontre contrairement à ce qu'on
entend parfois voire souvent que notre
pays ait gouvernable c'est à dire
qu'avec une majorité relative on peut
gouverner le pays puisque il ya une
présidente de l'assemblée nationale
demain il y aura moins à lire des
instances demain on peut au moins et
dires des uns c'est à dire se permettent
ce qui permet c'est plus compliqué à
mettre l'institution va continuer de
fonctionner non parce que papa là la
question tout le monde se plaignait
jusqu'à
au mois d'avril au bar au mois de juin
tout le monde se plaignait d'un
parlement affaibli par la majorité
absolue aujourd'hui on entend dire
quelle tragédie il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue quelle tragédie on voit ça peut
être une opportunité mais la tragédie
c'était quand même une majorité absolue
puisqu'il ya qu'est ce qu'il y avait un
hyperprésident
pour moi aujourd'hui nous rentrons dans
la pratique si on fait un peu de droit
comparé et excusez-moi la pratique
européenne l'allemagne l'espagne la
belgique les pays bas fin tous les pays
où exactement aucun pays à part
peut-être le portugal et la grèce je
suis pas sûr pour la grèce mais pour le
portugal aucun pays n'a un parlement où
il existe une majorité absolue ce qui
veut dire que dans tous les pays c'est
soit des gouvernements de coalition soit
des lois qui sont votées en fonction des
extraits à la différence près c'est que
ce sont dès le départ des régimes
parlementaires et mais nous sommes à
l'écart de la france est claire dans un
régime hybride il n'y a pas de chef
d'état au plan européen qui ait autant
de pouvoir que les gens qu'on semble
présidentielle le président de la
république n'a de pouvoir que si il a
une majorité absolue la situe la
constitution et ses articles 20 et 21
c'est le premier ministre qui détermine
oui sauf que et conduit alors quand le
quand le c'est là où je comprends pas
les commentaires quand il ya une
majorité absolue ce qui attend les
députés se font élire sur le nom du
président en 2017 ils sont pas fait
élire sur le nom d'edouard philippe mais
sur le nom de macron sur en 2007 ils
sont pas faits et dires sur le nom de
fillon mais sur l'angle sarkozy ils sont
pas faiblir sur de mauroy mais sur le
nom de mitterrand dont vous avez une
majorité soumise au président puisqu'ils
doivent leur élection au président
aujourd'hui la situation est différente
puisque macron pourra pas se représenter
en 2027 donc les députés sont autonomes
par rapport au président est donc
maintenant il va falloir rentrer dans la
structure est dans la logique
parlementaire où vous êtes pour une un
fonctionnement parlementaire et vous
devriez être content de la situation
actuelle puisque ça va conduire
à des négociations à des délibérations à
des compromis il faut pas oublier qu'il
ya un groupe qui a la majorité et les
autres chez mintel le
constitutionnaliste que vous êtes se
régale forcément de la situation et on
le comprend forcément on va y revenir
mais on va quand même revenir à
l'élection du jour elle ça monte à gabat
vous avez suivi pendant plus de quatre
heures cette longue journée d'élection
quelle est la température ce soir salle
des quatre colonnes au fond les
différents groupes comment ont-ils vécu
cette élection de yale brune peavey au
perchoir eh bien écoutez l'est derrière
moi il n'y a quasiment plus personne
salle des quatre colonnes mais il faut
s'imaginer qu'ils avaient trois cent
quinze journalistes accrédités plus tous
ceux qui ont une accréditation
permanente comme nous à la chaîne
parlementaire alors comment ça s'est
passé et bien pendant que les députés
voter comme ils tirent au sort une
lettre finalement ils savent à peu près
à quel moment ils vont être appelés dans
l'hémicycle donc ils faisaient des
aller-retours salle des quatre colonnes
pour répondre aux questions des
journalistes
alors au début évidemment pour défendre
leur candidature
et puis pour évoquer évidemment les
différentes élections qui vont avoir
lieu demain le bureau de l'assemblée
après demain la commission des finances
ils sont revenus aussi certains sur les
propos et stéphane blakowski vous en
parlais du doyen de l'assemblée
nationale josé gonzalez sur l'algérie
française et puis à la fin du premier
tour quand les députés ont été appelés
pour connaître les résultats dans
l'hémicycle notre collègue de la chaîne
parlementaire marque au pommier a eu
vent d'une rumeur sébastien chenu retiré
sa candidature on en a eu la
confirmation à quelques instants plus
tard dans l'hémicycle et ça eh bien tout
le monde a sorti la calculatrice pour
voir si yaël brawn pie v avec
l'abstention des voix du fn pouvait être
élu au deuxième tour on a vite compris
que normalement ça passait mais
évidemment tout le monde a attendu les
opérations de vote de ce second tour il
y a eu des critiques de la nuque
considérant et bien que c'était ce
retrait du rassemblement national qui
permettait l'élection de yaël brawn pie
v et puis à la fin léger cafouillage
puisqu'on a appris l'élection de la
présidente de l'assemblée nationale hier
une vive et non pas par le doyen quand
il a proclamé les résultats mais par un
tweet du ministre des relations avec le
parlement olivier véran très bien
informé visiblement et puis comme vous
l'avez dit ensuite il ya le banquier
monte à la tribune pour un discours
plein d'émotion elle est au petit hôtel
de la séance moment pour la passation de
pouvoir avec l'ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
merci beaucoup elsa monde à gaza et
merci à toutes les équipes des tp qui
nous ont accompagnés toute la journée
alors qu'ils étaient là elles brawn
peavey la présidente de l'assemblée
nationale est novice en politique elle
est arrivée en 2017 avec la vague d'
emmanuel macron elle s'est ensuite
imposée comme présidente de la
commission des lois portrait cinéma
roubaix coeur
j'espère qu'ensemble nous poserons la
dernière pierre de la parité de cet
édifice de la parité en réponse à
catherine tasca à ses alliés elle disait
alors que le chemin était encore long
nous avons aujourd'hui l'opportunité
ensemble dans parcourir le dernier
kilomètre pour les femmes pour les
femmes politiques et pour toute la
société c'était en février imaginé tel
déjà devenir la première femme
présidente de l'assemblée nationale y
est lebron peavey est l'une des
révélations de la dernière législature
devenu une figure incontournable du
palais bourbon en juin 2017 contre toute
attente l'ex avocate novice en politique
bas dans les yvelines l'un des piliers
de la droite à l'assemblée elle est élue
quelques jours plus tard à la surprise
générale présidente de la commission des
lois un poste prestigieux d'habitude
réservé à des parlementaires
expérimentés c'est la deuxième femme à
accéder à cette présidence vingt ans
après catherine tasca elle est aussitôt
raillée critiquée
vous savez madame panneaux le parlement
depuis presque deux ans à jouer
pleinement son rôle ne vous en déplaise
l'opposition dresse contre elle un
procès en incompétence
a rapidement la sphère benalla éclate ya
lebron privées dirigent la très chahuté
commission denquête
disponibles
si on veut commencer de la sérénité du
coup que chacun d'entre eux une fois
installé correctement un baptême du feu
bien souvent ce n'était pas des
questions qu'ils souhaitaient poser mais
en faire à nouveau une tribune
médiatique là il souhaiterait bloquer le
fonctionnement de la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale
ça n'arrivera pas la commission des lois
continuera à fonctionner et il faut être
garant du fonctionnement de nos
institutions c'est ce à quoi je
m'attache depuis le début de cette
procédure mais cette bûcheuse acharné
réussit finalement à convaincre
l'ensemble de ses collègues par son
style et son approche de terrain elle
renouvelle ce rôle clé de l'assemblée
quand j'ai pris mes fonctions à la
commission des lois je me suis très
rapidement poser la question pourquoi je
suis là quelle est la raison de ma
présence
à la tête de cette commission des lois
et qu'elle va être qu'elle emprunte je
vais laisser et le sujet de les prisons
s'est tout de suite imposé à moi elle
multiplie les visites dans l'univers
carcéral avec ses députés une
collégialité une indépendance salué sur
tous les bancs même parmi les plus
féroces opposants à la macro ni à droite
comme à gauche libre elle prend parfois
ses distances avec la majorité comme
lorsqu'elle convaincre le gouvernement
d'exempter les 12 15 ans du pass
vaccinale ou lorsqu'elles s'engagent en
faveur de la proposition de loi
autorisant l'euthanasie
philippe gosselin vous a beaucoup vu
dans ce sujet vous avez très énervé au -
delà de la sphère benalla de la
commission d' enquête qui a été enterrée
comment at-elle réussi yaël boon peavey
à faire tourner cette page pour
finalement s'imposer au perchoir il ya
eu effectivement plusieurs phases la
phase benalla était la phase on va dire
d'apprentissage les 12 13 premiers mois
qu'on était quand même un peu compliqué
conflictuelle mais qu'ils ont été en
réalité pour toute la majorité est pour
tout le monde après je crois qu'il ya
réellement eu un travail de fond on a
été plusieurs à travailler sur le sujet
des prisons on a un rapport commun avec
yaël boon privé des tensions sur le
travail
ensemble dans des commissions mais
il ya une volonté en tout cas de bien
faire et ça personne ne peut la mettre
en cause on a aussi travaillé beaucoup
sur les outre mer elle a évoqué
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans son
discours d'investiture on va le dire
ainsi en tout cas de proclamation de
résultats les outre mer et elle a raison
donc voilà je pense que c'est une femme
de deux passerelles maintenant par
moments il se réduit elle est aussi une
femme de la majorité et c'est bien
légitime voilà tout ça fait un tableau
plutôt bienveillant ce qui me concerne
et la bienveillance c'est pas la
compromission mais elle aura fort à
faire dans une assemblée où il va y
avoir des tranchées ouvertes où certains
veulent quand même mener une guérilla on
voit bien déjà certains propos
aujourd'hui plus compliqué que d'autres
égards yade
je juge bruguière aussi jean rémy c'est
qu'elle ne serait pas là si un certain
richard ferrand elle a eu du
facteur chance dire que sur les
dernières années en fait elle a eu du
mal à s'imposer effectivement récemment
l'un des exemples les plus récents c'est
que richard ferrand avait bien vu
qu'elle lisait le perchoir et qu'il a
tout fait pour l'écarter de manière je
dirais assez stratégique pour la pousser
vers le gouvernement puisqu'elle a été
donc à la réélection de d'emmanuel
macron donc en charge des outre-mer donc
richard ferrand pensait finalement
l'avoir mis de côté mais de fait lui
même perd son père son siège et donc
d'une certaine manière ça lui fait de la
place parce qu'elle n'était pas elle
n'était pas la candidate des manuels
macron un pourri s'occupe de l'affairé
roland lescure donc elle a aussi dû
d'une certaine manière à aller au delà
de la delà de ce que vous entendez dire
que c'était voilà s était une femme de
la majorité mais au sein de la majorité
n'a pas toujours eu que des amis edouard
philippe été très dur avec elle très
très dur avec elle et puis souvent elle
était pas tout à fait prise au sérieux
est ce que c'était parce que c'est une
femme c'est évidemment la question est
posée mais d'une certaine manière elle a
dû bien point par point comme ça a
avancé alors la configuration politique
est telle que les à une place où elle
n'aurait peut-être on a pris les
commandes et négocier et pour discuter
c'est ça un groupe alors on passe
tranquillement à dominique rousseau d'un
instant quelle est la fonction que lui
attribue la constitution parce qu'on
veut savoir quel sera ses marges de
manoeuvre exactement ce qui est
intéressant et j'ai veillé à lebron
pires et qu' elle vient de la société
civile au fond elle incarne la promesse
d' emmanuel macron c'est à dire vous
voulez vous engager vous croyez au
dépassement vous cliquer peut-être que
vous serez investissez ce qui lui est
arrivé et finalement elle a même été
président d'une commission des lois elle
n'avait pas de réseau on citait
christophe castaner richard ferrand tous
ces anciens socialistes vous même vous
venez un peu du sérail politique vous
n'êtes pas voilà est ce que est ce que
c'est ça qui a séduit au fond elle
incarne ce qu emmanuel macron a voulu au
fond faire régénérer le personnel
politique je crois que elle elle incarne
en tout cas effectivement cette
possibilité cette chance qui est donnée
à la société civile de venir s'intégrer
dans un paysage politique et d'y prendre
des responsabilités lorsqu'on a de la
compétence mais je tiens quand même à
rappeler que c'est une femme qui est
avocate c'est une femme qui a démontré
ses progrès vous en parlez donc sa
capacité non seulement à écouter mais à
apprendre et à maîtriser tous les
rouages petit complexe de cette
assemblée que moi je vais découvrir dans
les semaines et mois à venir et puis
c'est une femme de gauche fibre sociale
est là elle a travaillé au restaurant du
coeur à se retirer sans moi le maquereau
nisme c'est à dire ceux cette confiance
en la société civile en solutions
pragmatiques qu'ils font à la fois la
solidarité envers les plus fragiles et
qui ne méprise pas l'activité économique
le développement l'investissement de
l'attractivité de nos territoires et
puis elle incarne aussi une femme de
détermination et nous en tant que femmes
et hommes de la majorité présidentielle
on extrêmement fière qu'elle est cette
fonction parce que il ne faut pas se
dire que c'est parce que il y à d'autres
personnes qui n'ont pas eu les positions
que on à aurore bergé il ya une protéine
allemands vivent et s'aperçut personnes
vanessa d'illégitimité elle n'y a pas de
profil mais c'était là le scénario
c'était pas le scénario prévu corps ma
vie qui coule bin alawi connaissent et
l'ensemble de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui de façon totalement inédite
dans l'ensemble de l'assemblée nationale
et qui va alors découvrir une nouvelle
histoire quatrième personnage de l'état
absolument et quelle fonction lui
attribue la constitution précisément
parce qu'il ya la lettre et puis après à
l'esprit donc président de l'assemblée
alors président de l'assemblée nationale
vous l'avez rappelé donc c'est le
quatrième personnage de l'état en tant
que présidente de l'assemblée nationale
et là des pouvoirs propres par exemple
nommer des membres du conseil
constitutionnel par exemple être
consulté le cas échéant avant une
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale la
concertation est obligatoire dans le
présent n'est pas obligé de suivre
l'avis du président de l'assemblée
nationale mais la consultation est
obligatoire elle peut saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
donc elle a des pouvoirs propres ce ne
sont pas nécessairement les plus
importants on nomme pas un membre du
conseil constitutionnel tout le tous les
matins et on ne saisit pas le conseil
non plus tous les manuels et la pression
tous les matins mais il n'y a pas de
déchets déjà président de tous les
députés c'est très important des 577
elle vient d'un conte mais elle va
devoir maintenant non gérer l'ensemble
ne se sentent pas tout à fait un hasard
j'ai pas eu le temps d'entendre
totalement le discours mais je crois
qu'elle a rendu hommage à jean louis
debré et jean louis debré on peut
discuter de sa fonction en tant que
ministre de l'intérieur il a été un très
bon président de l'assemblée nationale
parce que venant à l'époque c'était de
l'ump je crois venant de de ce groupe là
qui était à l'époque majoritaire il a su
laisser parler et faire parler les
groupes d'opposition il les a respectés
y compris lorsqu'ils déposent est plus
de cinq mille amendements susurre un
texte et le fait qu'elle se soit référée
à jean louis debré alors on peut dire
que c'est un coup d'oeil howell r oui
bon d'accord on n'en sortira jamais
mais il a su se hisser je pense que
c'est aux de l'ensemble les aînés la
prise jean louis debré c'est parce que
jean-louis debré a été effectivement un
président qui est sorti en quelque sorte
de ceux de son groupe pour être le
représentant de l'ensemble des députés
au qu'il faut être impartial d'ailleurs
le dialogue entre nous le dialogue avec
les français savoir sortir hors les murs
et renouvelée en fait mais quelles sont
les qualités d'un bon président la
qualité d'un bon président alors là ça
dépend si on est en mesure il donne au
président un
bon président c'est celui qui fait voter
des lois voulues par les lisières l'a
fait ça c'est un bon président qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un bon président lorsqu'il
n'y a pas de majorité absolue c'est un
président qui essaie avec les présidents
et les présidentes eu de groupe de
construire texte par texte ce que guère
faire appel et majorité d'idées c'est à
dire de construire en fonction des
sujets des majorités et ça c'est le rôle
notamment de la présidente de
l'assemblée nationale autrement dit le
le pouvoir va glisser la part
complètement basculé pendant plus rêver
mais il va glisser
vers comment dire le ministre des
relations avec le parlement les
présidents de groupe et le président de
l'assemblée nationale évidemment le
premier ministre donc on va avoir ce
glissement donc le rôle de président de
l'assemblée nationale va être
déterminant et dire que pour vous
à partir du moment où ça réhausse le
rôle du parlement mécaniquement sa
réhausse l'importance du président de
l'assemblée nationale le président de la
média dans la construction des mazures
et là ça veut dire si je vous comprends
bien que le lien avec les députés les
différents groupes les respecter les
écouter dégager des consensus et presque
plus important que le lien avec le
président de la république on va écouter
comment elle conçoit son rôle et puis je
vous passe la parole juste après dans
notre assemblée est inédite les français
nous enjoignent de travailler ensemble
de débattre plutôt que de nous battre
ils nous ont choisis ils nous ont été
lus et nous partageons quelles que
soient nos différences une
responsabilité celle de répondre à
l'espoir que cette assemblée qui a le
visage de la france a fait naître sur
nos concitoyens l'espoir de nous voir
sortir de ces querelles stériles que
l'on nous approchons souvent reproché
voilà débattre et non pas se battre jean
rémi baudot ce n'est pas une membre du
premier cercle des manuels macron pas du
tout et c'est ce qui fait comme on le
disait tout à l'heure qu'elle n'était
pas la candidate des manuels macron à ce
poste puisque lui elle sera présente à
toutes les réunions stratégiques basse
et c'est la question qui va se poser
c'est à dire que jusqu'à présent richard
ferrand était un peu et faisait partie
des grognards autour d'eux des manières
macro et c'était lui qui tirait les
ficelles d'un point de vue politique
c'est à dire que c'était aussi ce qui
faisait dire que peut-être à matignon il
pouvait y avoir une personnalité plus
technique puisqu'il y avait à la tête de
l'assemblée nationale une personnalité
extrêmement politique
la configuration a totalement changé ça
va être très intéressant de voir dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois quelle
place skis emmanuel macron donne
heilbronn pie v dans son entourage dans
ces fameuses réunions de la majorité et
ce qu'ils l'écoutent
parce que effectivement elle va avoir un
rôle de négociateur
en tant que présidente de l'assemblée
nationale
et ça c'est un rôle qui va être
renforcée par par sa position et c'est
vraiment intéressant ce qui va se passer
forcément il faut rappeler que c'est
refaire en fait toutes les investitures
des députés que vous êtes dans la
majorité ensemble oui il est venu même
nous soutenir la ce qui crée un lien
particulier avec ses services
particuliers est ce qu'il est ce que
vous vous pensez qu'elle sera aussi
faire preuve d'autorité parce que c'est
bien beau de trouver des consensus mais
on s'attend quand même à peu de brou
avoir de tension dans l'hémicycle c'est
une flamme ça peut-être y sait se faire
obéir d'une certaine manière ça peut
être un sujet comme son poids politique
peut-être un sujet c'est clair on l'a
dit ferrand avait dû savoir faire il
avait une certaine autorité ça peut être
un peu différent pour yaël brune puis
vais maintenant vous savez moi je fais
partie de ceux qui pensent que les
situations révèle les personnalités et
que ce soit elle ou d'autres les
fonctions font que avec son expérience
son passé une forme de combativité je
pense qu'effectivement elle peut elle
peut étonner voilà ça veut pas dire que
je suis sous le charme ça veut pas dire
les oppositions vont renoncer mais par
moments il faut aussi faire confiance et
est juste pour rebondir quelques
instants sur peut-être ce moment un peu
particulier que nous vivons si
effectivement on a un parlement qui dans
quelques semaines quelques mois peut
être revalorisé alors que j'estime qu'il
a été dans un corner il a été vraiment
mais pratiquement piétiné pendant cinq
ans est bien collectivement on pourra
s'en réjouir et ça ça devrait réjouir
tous les démocrates de france 9 heures
dominique rousseau un président ou une
présidente de l'assemblée nationale qui
n'est pas en lien direct avec le chef de
l'état le couple exécutif ça s'est déjà
montré dans l'histoire ça s'est déjà
produit il ya eu quelques cas où le
président de l'assemblée nationale a été
élu contre le candidat pressenti par le
par le président république a eu la
querelle edgar faure ou chaban-delmas
par exemple y compris d'ailleurs au
début en 58 n'est pas sûr que
général de gaulle michel debré était
très content que jacques chaban delmas a
été élu député président de l'assemblée
nationale oui il ya eu il ya eu des cas
où le prêt d'un république n'a pas pu
faire élire son candidat et c'est très
bien si on est si on est excusez moi pas
si on est je pense que la vème
république a une structure parlementer
l'expliqué les spectateurs parce qu'on
entend toujours la cinquième république
le général de gaulle au moins
semi-présidentiel c'était
là une structure parlementaire
c'est-à-dire que le régime parlementaire
c'est le gouvernement qui est
responsable devant l'assemblée nationale
et la possibilité de dissoudre si vous
avez ces deux éléments la responsabilité
et dissolution vous avez un régime
parlementaire la meilleure théoriquement
la meilleure preuve complexe où là c'est
la meilleure preuve la meilleure preuve
c'est que quand un président n'a pas de
majorité
il est tout nu excusez moi mais quand
jacques chirac a perdu la majorité en
1997 c'est lyon ne lâche pas et recel à
ces deux parlements et le premier ce
qu'ont décidé et jacques chirac étaient
contre le pacs il ya eu le pacs il était
content et ému il ya eu la cmu il était
compté 35 heures il ya eu les 35 heures
il était content le quinquennat il ya eu
le quinquennat ça montre la plasticité
de nos institutions mais cris qui qui
peut être qu'ils peuvent être
parlementaire dans des conditions très
strictes mectizan chez par ex oui
peut-être peut-être on verra mais qui
par exception sont plutôt parlementaires
parce qu'encore une fois on a un
président sous la vème république qui a
des pouvoirs qu'aucun autre président
dans les autres démocraties occidentales
en tout cas je ne suis pas d'accord
alors
n'y a pas des pouvoirs qui lui
permettent de gouverner il à la
dissolution ils nous ont dit sue pas
tous les jours non mais on est d'accord
on dans mes hommages celui qui a les
manettes c'est le premier ministre après
le ballon
de la nation et plus tôt le président de
la république henri
médias juste une chose qu'on va devoir
observer dans les prochains jours c'est
quand c'est qu'il va y avoir un
remaniement est dans la configuration
avec cette nouvelle géométrie où il y as
au perchoir donc une personnalité qui
n'est pas forcément en proximité avec
emmanuel macron quelle place par exemple
pour olivier ferrand ministre des
relations en charge du parlement qui ont
cessé un peu retrouvé là un tout petit
peu par hasard il n'y avait pas
forcément
les épaules pour ce job là et c'est là
qu'on va voir aussi est-ce que lors du
remaniement il va y avoir une reprise en
main de ce poste là pour peut-être
placer quelqu'un de plus politique voilà
c'est des choses qui n'est pas forcément
le ministre de la majorité relative les
épaules peut-être le caractère ça c'est
à voir ça c'est avoir les émergents il
est trop colérique pour vous il n'est
pas simple à manier enfin on en a on a
vu ce que ça a donné au moins vous dans
les deux les deux heures de
cette marche arrêt c'est là où il faut
vraiment qu'on garde confiance
effectivement dans dans ses capacités de
révélation d'une femme qui vient d'être
élu ça nous donne confiance en l'avenir
et puis c'est ce qu'attendent les
français ils n'ont pas voté pour
l'immobilisme ils veulent un parlement
qui soit le visage de la france comme
elle l'a dit et un parlement qui puisse
réellement débattre et décider merci
beaucoup on va évidemment continuer à
débattre de cette journée avec notre
grand témoin présent merci je vous garde
avec moi dominique rousseau un instant
parce qu'on a une question justement de
constitutionnalité à vous poser on
accueille à présent merci à tous une
figure de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale matile de panneaux
qui pilote le groupe des 72 des insoumis
à l'assemblée la coalition de gauche qui
s'est scandalisé on l'a dit tout à
l'heure d'un moment particulier dans
l'hémicycle regardez ce symbole d'unité
touche l'enfant d'une france d'ailleurs
que je suis arraché à sa terre natale
hydro c'est sur les côtes de provence
alpes par le vent de l'histoire 1962
j'ai laissé là bas une partie de ma
france et beaucoup d'amis je suis un
homme qui a vu son âme à jamais
meurtries
excusez moi je pense à mes amis que j'ai
laissé là bas
je suis un bon soir matt hill de
panneaux et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir vous présidez le groupe de la
france soumise à l'assemblée nationale
député du val-de-marne alors un grand
nombre de unes 75 membres 75 pardonnez
moi pour que vous ne glissez
75 députés n'ont pas 72 autant pour moi
vous avez été comme bon nombre de vos
collègues choqué par par les mots du
doyen d'âge à eau au perchoir bien sûr
d'autant plus que derrière il a été aux
quatre colonnes réitéré des propos sur
révisionnistes sur la question de l'eau
est sûre la part française qui l'aurait
laissée dans l'algérie française pour
lequel il a une nostalgie je pense
effectivement que c'est très choquant
pour un premier discours du rn qui
affiche la bon un révisionnisme
révisionnisme car oui bah oui oui
franchement enfin la question de la
guerre d'algérie est une question
extrêmement sensible est une question
coloniale et je crois qu'à voir
quelqu'un qui le premier jour de
l'assemblée au perchoir
prononce de deux tels mots et les
réitère ensuite aux quatre colonnes
n'est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on
aurait attendre un dos qu'on aurait pu
attendre d'une première journée à
l'assemblée nationale alors votre
première réaction et l'élection de gaël
brawn qui va vous avez voté contre son
élection deuxième tour nous avons voté
pour notre candidate ce qui est
également légitime mais vous connaissez
bien belle brune pied mais est-ce que
vous pouvez lui ce soir de dire on a
plutôt confiance elle va elle va essayer
de rassembler elle a fait un discours
débattre plutôt que se battre convaincus
ou pas non je vais vous dire pourquoi
c'est pas assez pas de l'opposition
stérile déjà dire que rennes stérile sur
des choses qui sont des grands débats de
fond moi j'ai géré mon plus gros
problème avec la macro ni je vais vous
expliquer c'est que pendant cinq ans
nous avons été la chambre
d'enregistrement du président pendant
cinq ans il ya eu une forme de négation
de la démocratie qui est que en
démocratie il y à différents programmes
politiques qui s'affrontent et que nous
avons été élus pour défendre différents
programmes politiques et que c'est
normal en démocratie qu'on débatte que
ensuite le vote à l'assemblée tranche
les choses mais qu'on puisse propair
proposer différents chemins au pays et
je crois que il ne faut pas aller vers
une sorte de thatchérisme où il n'y
aurait pas d'alternative à ce qui est
proposé ce qu'on nous a beaucoup répété
pendant le coc vie donc le maquereau nu
des mois pour ce qui m'inquiète avec
madame ya où il ya et lebron privée ce
n'est pas sa personne mais c'est que
c'est notamment elle qui comme
présidente de la commission des lois à
en tirer sur ordre de l'elysée la
commission denquête benalla a refusé
d'entendre notamment monsieur alexis
colère et donc d'entendre les différents
personnages de l'elysée sur cette
affaire et je crois que c'est un mauvais
signal sur le fait que madame yaël boon
qui fait comme présidente de l'assemblée
doit être la garante des droits
parlementaires et notamment des droits
de contrôle de l'assemblée sur le
gouvernement un des premiers textes
mathilde panneaux que la nuit ps va
déposer vise à inscrire le droit à
l'avortement dans la constitution après
le choc planétaire qu'a provoquée la
décision de la cour suprême américaine
beaucoup de députés notamment en france
où est gravé dans le marbre ce droit
pour toutes les femmes on va en parler
avec vous ainsi qu'avec vous dominique
rousseau juste après ce sujet de thibaut
enoch
une décision historique mais à rebours
de l'histoire par cinq voix contre
quatre vendredi dernier les juges de la
cour suprême américaine abroge l'arrêt
roe versus wade datant de 1973 voilà les
états unis revenus 50 ans en arrière au
temps où chaque état pouvait décider de
légaliser ou non l'avortement
une décision immédiatement acclamé par
les anti ivg est célébrée par le camp
conservateur donald trump en tête
la cour a prononcé une victoire pour la
constitution une victoire pour l'état de
droit et surtout une victoire pour la
vie
l'ancien président à qui est cette
décision doit beaucoup lui qui a nommé
trois juges conservateurs à la cour
suprême avant son départ de la maison
blanche laissant son successeur démunis
face au fait accompli
c'est la réalisation d'une idéologie
extrémiste et une erreur tragique de la
cour suprême dans les heures qui suivent
le camp progressiste abasourdi ne peut
que constater les dégâts
à peine la décision de la cour suprême
rendue huit états américains déclarent
tout avortement illégal comme ici dans
le missouri sept autres ont prévu de
faire de même dans les prochaines
semaines dans le texas
une onde de choc qui s'est répandu
jusqu'en france où elle s'est invitée
dans le débat politique avec une
question faut-il sanctuariser le droit
lives et j'ai en l'inscrivant dans la
constitution
c'est la proposition de la nouvelle
présidente du groupe renaissance aurore
bergé
malheureusement rien est impossible et
les droits des femmes sont toujours des
droits qui sont fragiles je pense qu'il
ne faut prendre aucun risque en la
matière et donc le sécuriser en
l'inscrivant dans le marbre de notre
constitution aussitôt soutenu par la
première ministre elisabeth bornes
l'idée divise cependant la majorité à
l'instar du président du modem françois
bayrou je ne suis pas pour qu'on décale
que la vie politique américaine est-ce
qu'il est beau est-ce qu'il est utile de
faire ça alors même que à ma
connaissance aucun courant politique ne
remet en cause la loi veil aucun courant
politique visé par certains le
rassemblement national a cependant dû
éclaircir sa position
aucun mouvement politique sérieux ne
remette en cause en france la loi veil a
qui a protégé le gouvernement
instrumentalise ce qui relève de la
politique intérieure américaine pour
faire diversion une vérité d'aujourd'hui
n'est pas forcément d'hier en 2012
marine le pen défend des le
déremboursement de ce qu'elle appelait
alors les ivg de confort
matile panneaux il ya des élus anti
avortement dans cet hémicycle avoue
penser ah oui c'est une évidence si vous
voulez je vous en je vous lis quelques
déclarations de certains des députés
rassemblement national qui montre que
willy un vrai danger sur cette question
là je vais vous lire juste cette phrase
de caroline parmentier qui écrit en 2018
qu'elle regrettait qu'après avoir
génocide et les enfants français à
raison de 200 mille par an ce qui est le
nombre d'avortements chaque année dans
notre pays on doivent maintenant les
remplacer à tour de bras par les
migrants caroline parmentier christophe
bentz député lui aussi rassemblement
national l'avortement est un génocide de
masse lors la valette qui avait publié
un texte en 2014 qui demandait tout
simplement la suppression de
l'avortement et je pourrais continuer
longtemps et d'ailleurs vous avez aussi
d'aider et lui a l'air comme frédéric
reiss ou françois xavier lalanne que
pour vous aujourd'hui remettre en cause
il doit y est le nom de ce jeune homme
qui après les états unis peut-être dans
le sillage de ce qui se passe aussi en
pologne ou en hongrie attaque alors
peut-être pas directement depuis
l'assemblée nationale mais dans la
société vous voyez pointé la possibilité
de cette remise en cause c'est pour ça
que il faut aller plus loin pour
garantir ce droit vers la substitution
bien sûr mais nous nous proposons deux
d'inscrire le droit à l'avortement mais
d'ailleurs comme d'autres droit à
disposer de son corps le droit de mourir
dans la dignité et de mettre des
nouveaux droits dans cette constitution
depuis 2012 la première fois que jean
luc mélenchon le propose c'est 2012 à la
bastille et d'ailleurs j'ai proposé dès
vendredi soir avec la nouvelle union
populaire d'avoir justement être
inscriptions alors depuis aurore bergé a
proposé la même chose que vous l a même
déjà déposé sa proposition de loi
exactement là où il aime vous et qu'avez
vous expliquer pourquoi puisqu'il
faudrait un projet de loi si on voulait
vraiment avancer sur cette question là
donc on va nous expliquer pourquoi mais
juste oui il y a il ya des dangers
autour des droits des femmes nous voyons
des régressions à certains endroits du
monde mais même y compris en france
lorsqu'on voit le nombre de par exemple
de centres ivg qui sont fermés le
planning familial qui attaque et qui
laisse à penser que et c'est ce que
disaient les féministes depuis
extrêmement longtemps que les droits des
femmes ne sont jamais acquis la
violoniste le même temps le fait pas et
que je vais accepter de faire cause
commune sur voilà sur cette question-là
d'écrire de grave et sans prendre
l'avion d'ailleurs proposé en 2008 et en
2007 à dix à proposer avant ce qui avait
été refusé par la majorité je me réjouis
qu'il ya un revirement sur cette
question dominique rousseau quelles sont
les chances que cette proposition de loi
soutenue à la fois par le groupe de 75
des [__] soumis lançons de la nièce
de 151 151
on aimerait que les 245 de la majorité
relative présidentielle ça fait beaucoup
de députés quelle chance d'aboutir les
chances sont fortes si effectivement le
la nuque pêche les députés d'ensemble
quelques députés l'air quand même
sont d'accord avec l'inscription dans la
constitution de la liberté pour les
femmes nous disposer de leur corps et
donc de que de pouvoir avorter c'est le
cld ici c'est le désir pardon le texte
de la loi constitutionnelle peut-être
voté à la majorité par l'assemblée
nationale ça c'est quasiment certain
alors faudrait voir les leurs il faudra
qu'elle soit majorité d'actions prennent
un faux qu'aider la majorité au sénat en
termes identiques sur le schéma peut
s'amuser à bouger une virgule un point
virgule si simple alors regardez c'est
là c'est bon de voir comment le sénat va
réagir il imagine l'hypothèse juillet
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale et
une majorité au sénat le texte est voté
en termes identiques
ce que prévoit la constitution et c'est
là qu'il peut y avoir un débat c'est
lorsque la proposition
lorsque de la loi vient et de
département le référent le référendum
est obligatoire c'est le président qui
doit le décider
la cdc les automatiques lorsqu'une
lorsqu une révision de la constitution a
pour origine deux parlements le
référendum est obligatoire jamais
produit sa proposition de la concession
ça a été fait pour ça de gaulle a bien
pensé la chose pour éviter que les
parlementaires fassent des propositions
de révision de la constitution
il a 10 si vous faites une révision de
la constitution il y aura un référendum
au bout comme les parlementaires sont un
peu réticents à l'égard du référendum il
n'y a jamais eu de proposition là si ça
vient des parlementaires que ce soit la
nuit pêche ou
vous n'avez pas peur du référendum
bouger mais on change non mais il c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que ça pourrait
aller plus rapidement si c'était
directement un projet de loi du
gouvernement puisque à ce moment là ça
serait les deux chambres qui se
réuniraient et il y à la majorité
déclare en cinquième la proposition
noyade objets loi c'est pourquoi je
disais lorsque madame bornes dit qu'elle
est très favorable à cette inscription
dans la constitution donc revenons en
arrière par rapport à ce que ce qu'il
disait avant et ses fortes heureux
elle pourrait elle même proposé un texte
au titre du gouvernement ce qui
permettrait on va dire d'aller plus
rapidement mais je crois que nous avons
une majorité social dans le pays qui a
envie que ce droit soit inscrit dans la
constitution dont garantis et protégés
pour les années et les décennies à venir
et j'ai une pensée particulière
aujourd'hui parce que on parle des états
unis on peut parler d'un voisin européen
très proche qui est la pologne ou la une
dernière vous avez à la fois une femme
qui s'appelle isabelle et une autre qui
s'appelle agnieszka qui toutes les deux
sont mortes du fait d'avortements
clandestins et je veux juste le dire
pour celles et ceux qui s'interrogent
sur cette liberté qui est donné aux
femmes quand on regarde dans des pays et
s'est montré dans des études entre des
pays qui interdisent ou qui restent yann
très fortement l'avortement ou qui
autorise l'avortement vous avez à peu
près les mêmes nombre d'avortements par
an qui sont qui sont faits la question
c'est de savoir dans quel jeu sécurité
ils sont fait d'assurer donc avec des
femmes qui meurent du fait de ces
avortements clandestins on va suivre ça
de très près sur sur lcp parce que
d'abord c'est passionnant voilà de voir
que ce que ce sujet revient après ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis et c'est
important aussi de voir quels sont les
chemins parlementaire possible aussi
bien ici que pourquoi pas devant devant
le peuple merci beaucoup dominique
rousseau vous risquez avec nous at-il de
mathilde de panneaux c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour pour
leur parti pris ce soir céline bracq va
nous parler du palmarès du palmarès de
notre partenaire au doxa du mois de juin
et vous allez le voir il n'est pas très
bon pour le couple exécutif et puis
fanny guinochet pour l'économie alerte
rouge sur les comptes publics noah
franchi elles sont de ce soir et les
voici en plateau on va commencer avec
vous ces villes on soit alors le
palmarès au dock stade du mois de juin
l'exécutif s'écroule pas d'état de grâce
est pire montée de la défiance on va
voir la popularité des manuels macron
qui perd six points de popularité à 38%
d'opinions favorables contre 62 % de
mauvaises opinions et c'est pire encore
pour la première ministre elisabeth byrs
oui alors elle s'effondre complètement
alors pour la première fois on l'a testé
du coup au mois de mai et là donc en ce
mois de juillet elle perd 10 points
elisabeth bornes voudront 3% voilà
exactement à 33% alors il faut savoir
que jean castex qui n'était pas un
premier ministre très impopulaire
n'avait jamais atteint ce point bas et
donc on va dire que ça commence quand
même assez mal assez mal pour elle et il
va maintenant falloir qu'elle puisse
trouver des majorités en convainquant
les autres partis politiques dans
l'hémicycle et dans l'opinion on voit
qu'elle a pas de base solide et qu'elle
a même plutôt tendance cette base à se
dérober sous ses pieds parce que quand
vous regarder dans le détail de ses
soutiens en ximité partisane alors elle
est soutenue j'allais dire évidemment
par les sympathisants renaissance 74%
qui ont une bonne opinion d'elle mais
elle perd 14 fois auprès d'eux en un
mois et elle la une un petit socle chez
les sympathisants de droite alors c'est
vrai qu'elle a été beaucoup présentent
elles qui n'était pas connu du tout de
l'opinion comme une femme de gauche mais
en fait c'est plutôt la droite qui
l'apprécient et encore 51% c'est pas
très élevé vous voyez que chez à la
france est soumise aux arènes c'est
absolument catastrophique mais à gauche
c'est pas terrible non plus
sympathisants du parti socialiste 58%
mauvaises opinions sympathisants
d'europe écologie les verts 68 % de
bonnes opinions donc on voit que il n'y
a pas eu d'état de grâce et que là bas
on constaté ça le premier mois et puis
la deuxième mois après les législatives
eh bien il ya une grosse défiance dans
l'opinion côté rassemblement national et
du ps alors au contraire ces deux
formations d'opposition s'impose et
domine même alors quand dans leurs camps
respectifs à droite et à gauche oui
quand on prend l'ensemble de la gauche
et l'ensemble de la droite et ça c'est
assez nouveau en tout cas pour le
rassemblement national
alors on a un palmarès de l'adhésion qui
cumule la sympathie et le soutien on à
63% de code d'adhésion pour mélenchon
delestre de l'extrême gauche au ps et on
à 78% pour marine le pen l'a aussi sa
part des partis de droite traditionnelle
à l'extrême droite ce qu'on voit c'est
que jean luc mélenchon vous voyez
surclasse ses suivants de plus de 30
points alors edouard philippe ça peut
vous paraître un peu étonnant qu'ils
soient appréciés qui se situe entre jean
luc mélenchon à adrien 14 c'est à dire
qu'il est il a une relativement de
relativement des relativement bonne
opinion un peu partout à edouard
philippe donc deuxième après le député
du nord adrien 4 mars ça c'est pour les
la gauche et les moeurs rassemblement
national et les leaders l'a épaulé les
leaders du ps comme olivier faur etc
sont beaucoup plus loin pour la droite
là c'est vraiment très nouveau c'est à
dire qu'on a marine le pen qui à 78% de
soutien chez les sympathisants de droite
mais je parle bien de l'ensemble de la
droite juste devant fin même assez
largement devant jordan valley bardella
et edouard philippe encore lui et ce
dont on se rend compte c'est que
finalement eric zemmour en quelque sorte
à sublimer la dédiabolisation de marine
le pen c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui elle
est fortement appréciée y compris par
des sympathisants de droite qui jusque
là la rejeter quand même assez claret
elle devient finalement la première
opposante très clairement à droite pour
l'ensemble de ceux de cet espace
politique très large alors on voit aussi
dans votre enquête que ce sont des
partis qui ont l'atout principal ces
deux parties est reine et les filles et
du ps pardonnez moi et bien les deux
défendent et classes populaires et pour
autant quand on regarde dans le détail
leurs soutiens sont bien différenciés
oui c'est à dire que la défense des
classes populaires c'est le point
positif qui est le plus mise en avant
par les français et qui y est et c'est
d'ailleurs dans les classes populaires
qu'il ya le plus de soutien à la fois de
la nuit baisse est due et rai mais sinon
sociologiquement les voyait
effectivement il ya des grosses
différences c'est à dire que on va avoir
une du ps qui surperforment auprès des
jeunes en particulier les plus jeunes
les moins de 25 ans des plus urbain
notamment et le rn qui va conquérir
davantage
les milieux ruraux et les quinquas et on
voit bien vous voyez sur sûr c'est sûr
avec ses différents cela on voit d'un
côté la nuit passe de l'autre côté le
rassemblement national points communs
classes populaires mais après des
territoires assez différent ray ce qui
fait qu'en fait après ces législatives
on a finalement eu une sorte d'aura
ciment de troyes france c'est à dire que
des classes assez aisé plutôt urbaine
qui soutiennent le centre et qui
soutiennent fortement emmanuel macron et
sur la gauche et sur la droite des dé
la gauche extrême et sur la droite
extrême mais de plus en plus soutenus
par des sympathisants de gauche on va
dire traditionnels et des sympathisants
de droite traditionnelle c'est ces deux
partis politiques maintenant c'est trois
blocs différents et un devoir trouver
peut-être des consensus avec vous ça va
être faire partie de votre travail pour
pouvoir voter des textes à l'assemblée
nationale mais si le panneau c'est
intéressant de voir que quand on demande
aux français ce que ces deux formations
est reine ou du ps adhère à mes idées on
se rend compte que
la question des classes populaires est
très importante mais l'électorat vient
des classes populaires pour le fn - pour
votre électorat on voit qu'ils sont
plusieurs bains plus diplômés est ce que
quand on défend les classes populaires
ne pas avoir énormément de ce segment là
parmi son électorat n'est pas un
handicap non mais moi je suis prêt je
suis pas d'accord avec avec ça parce que
y compris je trouve que c'est pas les
chiffres qui ont été montrées là vous
vous avez eu un nombre de gens notamment
dans les quartiers populaires qui sont
des zones urbaines mais dans lequel vous
avez des milieux populaires qui se sont
déplacés très très largement sur la
présidentielle et sur la législative
enfin surtout sur sur la présidentielle
par ailleurs mais moi je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur quelque
chose parce que vous dites y'a 3 france
c'est effectivement ce que ce que ce
qu'on a remarqué notamment au premier
tour de la présidentielle avec
finalement trois grands blocs du pays le
bloc libéral celui d' emmanuel macron le
bloc autour de l'extrême droite et le
marine le pen et le bloc populaire que
nous incarnons et que nous avons en
quelque sorte unifiée avec la nouvelle
union populaire autour autour d'un
programme et c'est ce que nous
continuons à faire et par ailleurs je
vous disais première force d'opposition
à droite pour le rassemblement national
mais la première force d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale droite c'est la
nouvelle union populaire avec ses 151
députés et nous comptons bien
je les entendais petit pont qui je pense
à lcp ici va vous intéresser c'est que
nous sommes aussi dans un moment non 20
repart le mans series et la vie
politique et ça ça va être intéressant
justement d'arrêter avec juste un homme
le président de la république qui prend
quasiment l'ensemble des décisions mais
que le débat y compris dans cette
assemblée nationale certaine façon s&p
sont réjouis parce qu'on redevienne
la vie politique française fanny
aujourd'hui on a appris que le
traitement des fonctionnaires serait
revalorisée de 3 5% hier c'était le
blocage des loyers effectivement en ce
moment le gouvernement d'ici ces mesures
pouvoir d'achat c'est un énorme paquet
avec eux la revalorisation des pensions
de retraite le chèque qui sera donc
à la rentrée remis aux familles modestes
on parle d'un chèque de 100 euros + 50
euros par enfant pour 9 millions de
français c'est plus qu'attendu en tout
cas ce dont on nous parlait bref le
gouvernement distribue des aides pour
éviter la colère sociale et il en
distribuer de façon très dépensière
puisque ce sont des dizaines de
milliards d'euros a priori 30 milliards
d'euros et en même temps bruno le maire
tire la sonnette d'alarmé la cote
d'alerté est atteinte sur les comptes
publics exactement c'est ce qu'ils
disaient vous savez que la france
dépense plus qu'elle ne crée de richesse
depuis longtemps donc en fait on vit à
crédit et en ce moment s'il dit ça c'est
parce qu'un vrai changement les taux
d'intérêt augmentent et forcément bien
notre dette avant on empruntait de
l'argent à des taux négatifs là on est à
2 % sur des emprunts à 10 ans une date
qui avoisine les 3000 milliards d'euros
vous imaginez la charge de la dette ça
représente 114 % de notre pib de notre
richesse créée l'année prochaine ce ne
sera pas en fin d'année ça sera guère
mieux parce que le gouvernement vient de
faire tomber ses prévisions de
croissance trois sens à deux et demi
pour cent alors forcément bruno le maire
quand il dit ça c'est un clin d'oeil à
la droite et attention aux dépenses
publiques mais de l'autre côté il donne
aussi des gages du côté de la gauche à
la nuque avec la distribution de l'aide
on va voir si ça fait des heureux pas
sûr chemin en tout est possible c'est
schizophrène absolument c'est la
quadrature du cercle la dette qui
explose au moment où le pouvoir d'achat
n'a jamais été aussi important il faut
changer de logiciel économique et ce
alors on veut relancer la consommation
populaire créer ainsi de l'emploi et
aider les petites et les moyennes
entreprises et arrêter avec la logique
économique qui prévaut voilà quelque
chose de plus les salaires par les
débats sur le pouvoir d'achat puisque
c'est le premier texte d'urgence qui
arrive en juillet après la déclaration
de politique générale elisabeth bost
remercie infiniment merci merci massy de
panneaux d'être venu sur le plateau de
lcp merci à vous deux c'est la fin de
cette émission pardon pour le retard
allemand
[Musique]